a billionaire Democrat donor finally
gets pinched for sex with children and
the mainstream media are trying to play
it off as a Republican scandal we will
examine who exactly is Jeffrey Epstein
then can mermaids be black we will
analyze the Disney Little Mermaid non
traversée finally NBC says we need
reparations because mitch mcconnell's
family owned slaves or something i'm
michael knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
this is the big question of the day
Jeffrey Epstein is Jeffrey Epstein going
to take down every famous politician
that you've ever heard of or is Jeffrey
Epstein going to get off the hook again
he is this billionaire hedge fund
manager playboy who has been sleeping
with a ton of underage girls for a very
long time we'll examine the case what it
means what it means for Trump what it
means for Clinton what it means for all
the other famous people associated with
him but first we have got to thank our
friends over at rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans finding the right house is
not easy and I would know this because I
live in LA and every time I see a house
that I want there's some awful issue
with it either falls apart because of an
earthquake or usually it's just too
expensive
finding the right house is not easy
finding the right mortgage will be easy
because rocket mortgage makes it easy
their team of mortgage experts is
obsessed with finding a better way which
means that their number-one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you these guys are absolutely great
the mortgage process is just generally
horrific these guys have figured out the
best way they have industry lead leading
online lending technology developed in
the heart of Detroit rocket mortgage is
totally changing the game they're there
with a word winning client service and
support every step of the way
when we have questions about this
process I have a million questions about
the mortgage process you just kind of
feel like an idiot because you know I
think I should know this and I don't
don't worry rocket mortgage has you
covered they have incredible client
service Quicken Loans has helped
millions of Americans achieve their
dream of homeownership when you're ready
to purchase the home of your dreams they
will be there to help you to visit
rocket mortgage.com slash an old scanner
wles take the first step toward the home
of your dreams Equal Housing lender
licensed in all 50 states nmls consumer
access number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage as easy as that
who is Jeffrey Epstein you're probably
hearing a lot of conflicting things in
the press he's just one of those names
that's been floating around for a while
now and it's such an eye
because is this billionaire hedge fund
manager he's got ties to some of the
world's most prominent politicians he
was convicted of soliciting sex from a
minor and he's now been arrested for sex
trafficking and it also seems a for
possession of child pornography
this guy is SuperDuper rich he's a major
Democratic donor the media did not cover
him at all for over ten years now they
haven't covered his obvious crimes but
now that they think that they can tie
him to trump all of a sudden they're
going after him and frankly I encourage
it I say great bring it on I think
they're gonna hoist themselves by their
own petard here this guy is super rich
so in 1992 he owned the largest private
residence in Manhattan and he's got ties
to a lot of people not just Democrats
though he does have ties to a lot of
Democrats but he has ties to Bill
Clinton Donald Trump
Prince Andrew in the UK he's got ties to
Alan Dershowitz our friend of the show
and you know top lawyer in America Ken
Starr another very important lawyer and
judge he was the guy who was going after
Bill Clinton during the Lewinsky affair
major major people now something that
the media reports have gotten wrong on
this and have kind of clouded the issue
I think is that it's not uncommon for
very very rich people to know other very
very important people this is not
uncommon at all this is what happens I
mean this guy was a member of New York's
high society and when you're really rich
are you really famous or you're really
powerful you tend to know a lot of other
people who were really rich and really
powerful and really famous so Epstein
was no different and because Epstein did
do some philanthropic work because he
was a big name in charity he had even
more reason to know these people so
Jeffrey Epstein had this charitable
foundation they donated in 2003 thirty
million dollars to Harvard to establish
a mathematical biology and evolutionary
dynamics program there so he gets lauded
he goes around to high society Harvard
professors and graduates like Alan
Dershowitz say oh he's a great guy you
know I like Jeffery yeah he's fun to be
around
Trump gave a quote to this 2002 New York
magazine profile said oh yeah Jeffrey's
got a great social life
Bill Clinton said oh yeah Jeffrey headon
has a keen knowledge of global markets
and what Epstein seems to have done is
through his philanthropy through his
business interests he created this
collection of friends that's the word he
used he had a collection of friends that
were strategic he said quote I invest in
people be it politics or science it's
what I do so why was he investing in
people well we saw last time around in
2007 when he got pinched for soliciting
sex from children and for for other sex
crimes that he maybe was able to use
that collection of people to help him
get off the hook now he also had this
island this private island in the
Caribbean which is called little st.
James and he had a plane a very famous
or infamous plane that he would take to
and from this island and he would lend
out to his famous friends like Bill
Clinton and the plane was known as the
Lolita Express Lolita from the famous
novel about having sex with a young girl
so pretty shady guy why was it why did
he have this island ostensibly it's
because he ran his business for tax
purposes out of the Caribbean out of st.
Thomas and so he owned this island right
next door what was he doing on that
island I we already have some idea and
we're gonna hear a lot more as this
investigation goes on pretty shady dude
and the question also was how did he
make all his money I mean he was a
college dropout he had been a teacher
very briefly of high school students and
then he gets into finance he's working
at Bear Sterns
he leaves there he's working in his own
hedge fund even that is not totally
uncommon you know a this is one of the
marks they give to Trump they'll say Oh
Donald Trump he's not really as rich as
he says he is Oh Jeffrey Epstein he's
not really as rich as he says he is this
2002 New York magazine article which is
kind of the famous profile of him said
basically the same thing they suggested
he wasn't really as rich as he said they
quoted one Wall Streeter is saying he is
this mysterious Gatsby esque figure he
likes people to think that he's
very rich and he cultivates this air of
aloofness the whole thing is weird yeah
the whole thing is really weird
so that's the background on Jeffrey
Epstein what did he do
in 2005 the Palm Beach Police get a call
from a woman saying that Jeffrey Epstein
had invited her fourteen-year-old
stepdaughter over to his mansion and
molested her and that the stepdaughter
had also been invited by another female
friend and that there were these girls
kind of recruiting each other to go to
Epstein's mansion down in Palm Beach
police interviewed five of the alleged
victims they got 17 witnesses under oath
to describe all these things that
Epstein was doing they then go and they
investigate his mansion they find a high
school transcript in Epstein's trash
that's pretty weird I don't keep those
lying around my house they found photos
of the girls in his house some of the
documents suggested that Epstein had
installed video cameras to record the
sex with underage girls and this is
where the politicians come in he would
invite some of these prominent
politicians over presumably to have sex
with these young girls and he would
videotape them as well so now you've got
some evidence of maybe having stuff for
blackmail maybe to get his friends to
help him out in a pinch so this is where
it gets really dodgy politically the
police bring this heap of evidence to
the Palm Beach County Prosecutor Barry
Krisher who is a major Democrat Jeffrey
Epstein major Democrat and what does the
Democratic prosecutor do he basically
punched he basically just charges this
guy with one count of soliciting
prostitution not with having sex with
minors not with trafficking minors not
with possession of child pornography not
with any not was producing child
pornography
none of that what it looks like is a
sweetheart deal from a Democrat
prosecutor to a Democrat donor pedophile
child molester to help him get off the
hook now all of this is still basically
a local matter except for any evidence
of crimes that took place on his
airplane the Lolita Express wore on his
pride
Island evidence of crimes in those two
places make it a federal case it's no
longer just a local matter
so this investigation ends at the and
obviously it's taken up at the federal
level it ends in a 53 page indictment
that could have sent Jeffrey Epstein to
prison for life then in 2007 the then US
Attorney Alexander Acosta who's a
Republican who's now Trump's Labor
Secretary had Epstein plead guilty to
two state charges so you still think two
state charges this guy is a sick
pedophile who's flying all over God's
green earth on the lolita' expressed
with girls how you only going to get him
onto state charges well in a Kostas
defense at least he got Epstein to admit
to something at least he got Epstein on
the hook for something which the
Democratic prosecutor Krisher wasn't
going to do but because it was only two
state charges it was no longer a federal
matter this removed it from federal
hands it gave Epstein the sweetheart
deal and this guy accused of pretty
horrific crimes his punishment is 13
months not in federal prison not in a
really tough prison in the Palm Beach
County Jail in a private wing of the
Palm Beach County Jail and then wait for
it with 12 hours a day work release so
that he could go to his nice cushy
office and then return to the prison at
night he got at six days a week it's
also a little weird because in Palm
Beach County you're not supposed to get
work release if you're a sex offender so
everything about this deal stinks to
high heaven why would they give it to
him I mean look I get that he's a donor
but ultimately you know this is maybe
too much even for that here's the key
the agreement that they reached the
non-prosecution agreement granted
immunity to any potential
co-conspirators so who are the potential
co-conspirators could have been the
girls who were recruiting the other
girls to come to his mansion could have
been some of the socialites ghyslain
Maxwell as one of the women named who
helped to recruit these girls and it
could be all the rich famous businessmen
and CEOs and presidents and politicians
and whatever who have been associated
with him if they took part in any of
that criminal activity they are granted
immunity by this deal maybe that's what
this is all about so this past February
a federal judge ruled that the
prosecutors in 2007 had violated the
Crime Victims Rights Act by hiding the
non-prosecution agreement from the
30-plus girls who had accused Epstein of
molesting them so they said that that
the agreement itself is not valid
because they didn't the girls didn't get
to see it in June
federal prosecutors were arguing that
there was actually no legal basis for
violating the agreement obviously I'm
not expert in it first of all I'm not
expert in this area generally but nobody
is expert in this agreement because we
have no idea what's really in the
agreement so anybody who's telling you
well this is totally right this is
totally wrong they almost certainly have
no idea what they're talking about
that's what this whole process is about
it's unsealing this agreement it's
unsealing this investigation and it's
seeing what this guy was accused of and
who also was accused alongside him now
on Saturday this past Saturday just a
few days ago
Epstein gets arrested again not for
exactly the same crimes but for sex
trafficking
why because Epstein had the island
Epstein has his residence in New York
Epstein has his Palm Beach place he's
got a ranch in New Mexico very rich guy
how did Epstein get away with this for
so long some of the reasons are actually
pretty innocent he hired a dream team of
lawyers he hired apparently Alan
Dershowitz and Ken Starr these are two
of the greatest legal minds of their
generation and in our country there's
nothing nefarious about that you know
Jay Simpson hired the same lawyer Oh Jay
Simpson hired Alan Dershowitz OJ Simpson
obviously guilty as sin but everybody is
entitled to a defense and if you're a
very wealthy criminal you're gonna hire
the best lawyers that seems perfectly
fine
then what is being reported
that Epstein had in his own
investigators dig up dirt on the people
investigating him and on the families of
the people investigating him so he got a
nice dossier of potential blackmail
material that may have led to this how
else did he get away with it for so long
the media never reported on it
if it had been a Republican donor let me
tell you they would have reported on
this in two seconds but a democratic
donor they want to cover it up I mean
there's a guy there's a Democratic donor
in California who's killed two black men
he lures gay black men to his house he's
killed two of them that barely made the
news we talked about on the show a
little bit very few people are talking
about it Democratic donors get different
treatment in the mainstream media and
then what's the last reason his Epstein
has a lot of money simple as that money
is a very powerful tool and we can
complain about that all we want we can
deny that that matters but money has
always been very powerful that's why
people want money money is power pretty
simple so who is really implicated here
it is Trump gonna go down because of
this is Clinton gonna go down let's get
beyond just the headlines in the
innuendo it seems to be the case the
president Trump was pals with Jeffrey
Epstein
he gave this quote about how he's always
he's fun to hang around with and Jeffrey
really enjoys his social life he put it
in that 2002 to your newer magazine
piece this makes a little bit of sense
though because Jeffrey Epstein was a
member of Donald Trump's Country Club
mar-a-lago the club that Donald Trump
owns Jeffrey Epstein was a member ad so
it's not at least Donald Trump would
have one innocent reason to see Jeffrey
Epstein to pal around with him beyond
the insinuation that he was going on the
Lolita Express or something how about
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton gave a nice
quote about Jeffrey Epstein in that 2002
New York magazine profile but why was
Clinton hanging around with Jeffrey
Epstein president Trump and this is
being reported in very few places
President Trump predicted just a few
years ago that Epstein would take down
Bill Clinton here is Bill Clinton a nice
guy got a lot of problems coming up in
my opinion with the famous island with
Jeffrey Epstein a lot of problems a lot
of problems coming up with that famous
island got a lot of problems with
Jeffrey Epstein would president Trump
really have made that prediction that
Epstein was going to take down Bill
Clinton if Donald Trump were in serious
danger here as well I'm skeptical of
that I think Trump is a little too cagey
Trump is a little too strategic for that
now you might say that Donald Trump
doesn't know anything about Clinton's
relations to Jeffrey Epstein that's fair
Donald Trump has promoted conspiracy
theories President Trump especially when
he's going after the Clintons is willing
to throw spaghetti at the wall so I
wouldn't only believe the dodgy Clinton
Epstein connection on the word of
President Trump but Bill Clinton is
acting really really weird about this
and he's been caught in a couple serious
lies about his relationship with Epstein
which makes me think this guy's been up
to no good with his old buddy on the
lolita' Express here is as this news
broke here is the statement that
President Clinton released about his
relationship says quote President
Clinton knows nothing about the terrible
crimes Jeffrey Epstein pleaded guilty to
in Florida some years ago let me stop
you right there he knows nothing about
it he knows nothing about a very serious
story from a major Democratic donor and
from a friend of his that he's pal
around with for years knows nothing
about that's what you're trying to tell
me I don't think so he goes on or those
with which he has been recently charged
in New York in 2002 and 2003 President
Clinton took a total of four trips on
Jeffrey Epstein's airplane that's an
important detail one to Europe one to
Asia and two to Africa which included
stops in connection with the work of the
Clinton Foundation staff supporters of
the foundation and his Secret Service
detail traveled on every leg of every
trip he had one meeting with Epstein in
his Harlem office in 2002 and around the
same time maybe
one brief visit to Epstein's New York
apartment with a staff member in his
security detail okay hold on this is so
you're saying okay look he bare he
doesn't know anything about Epstein he's
never Epstein who well yeah he took his
his plane yeah well yeah he took it four
times all over the world well yeah he he
invited him to meet with him at his
Harlem office well yeah he stopped by
his private residence in New York but he
had people around him nothing to see
here nothing to see here folks then this
statement concludes he's not spoken to
Epstein and well over a decade and has
never been to little st. James Island
Epstein's ranch in New Mexico or his
residence in Florida okay first of all
no one's accusing Bill Clinton of going
to the island or the ranch in New Mexico
or the Florida residence people are
wondering why he was piling around with
Jeffrey Epstein so much why he was
flying all over on the lolita Express
notice that Clintonian language - he
took four trips on the airplane well
what were the four trips so the four
trips on the airplane one to Europe one
to Asia two to Africa how do you define
a trip on an airplane I guess it depends
on what the definition of trip is when I
when I fly to New York I live in LA I
fly to New York do I take one trip on an
airplane or do I take at least two trips
on an airplane I take one when I fly to
New York I take another when I fly back
from New York
that's not one trip on an airplane
that's two trips on an airplane Clinton
says he took four trips on the airplane
he took them to four places do you not
fly back he didn't come back from Europe
he's still over in Asia is he still over
in Africa I don't think so did he go
straight there and straight back maybe
did he stop at other places along the
way how much was he on that airplane
well we actually might have an answer to
that three years ago Fox News uncovered
flight records from the lalita Express
that showed that Bill Clinton had flown
on it 26 times not four times not even
four times four times 26 times
and that included according to the
flight records five trips without his
Secret Service detail that's a little
different cuz you wonder why does it why
is Clinton is responding here like a
like a guilty man he was always there
with a staff member he was always there
with a Secret Service detail he only did
it four times well you basically admit
in the statement itself it was more than
four trips unless he just stayed in
Europe unless he stayed in Asia we know
he didn't do that we're The Secret
Service there the whole time frankly
even if they were I'm not sure that that
matters that much no offense to the
secret sir I don't know a Bill Clinton
Secret Service detail
we just know from his time as governor
of Arkansas that he would regularly use
state employees to cover up his affairs
and his sexual abuses all around the
state we know we know that the detail
knew all about it
so what was it let's say he went on at
those five times according to the
records without the Secret Service
detail what occurred on that plane
why did he take that plane Bill Clinton
has access to lots of private planes why
did he take Jeffrey Epstein's it's been
reported that this plane has been fitted
out for weird sex that it includes a bed
where bizarre and unsavory activities
take place also on the flight records
with Bill Clinton were the names of
girls who are those girls one of the
girls was named Tatiana I don't mean to
stereotype but Tatiana doesn't sound
like a real hardcore butch secret
service member that no Stu Tatiana is a
very effeminate name I don't know I'm
just raising questions so how does this
really look for the people who are
implicated in being associated with him
doesn't bother me that famous people
associated with a billionaire famous
people associate with billionaires and
politicians in particular associate with
billionaires Dershowitz has been accused
of engaging in these sexual activities
by a witness that seems to me uncredible
her name is Virginia Roberts I believe
is her last name she was kind of the
main witness and she seems to have
contradicted herself a few times
Dershowitz has repeatedly and forcefully
denied all of the allegations against
him and Dershowitz has called for all of
the records to be unsealed so either he
is bluffing harder and more confidently
than anybody has ever bluffed or he
really feels that he'll be exonerated by
all of this and that he's the victim of
a of a false accusation why am i
inclined to believe Alan Dershowitz here
he was Epstein's lawyer he has a
perfectly legitimate reason to be
palying around with Epstein he is a very
obvious target for people to go after
because of that coordination and because
he was literally professionally
defending Epstein
so Dershowitz I think he looks fine so
if we will see what happens but it
doesn't seem to me that there's any hard
evidence that he did anything wrong
Ken Starr doesn't have any allegations
against him as far as I can tell
also a lawyer for for Jeffrey Epstein
looks safe enough so when you see those
names pop up in the in the reporting on
this I think it's a little bit of a
distraction have a president Trump now
president Trump has obviously less of a
reason to associate with Epstein than
Epstein's lawyers do but he ran the
country club that Epstein was a member
of it was a very exclusive club Trump
knows as far as we can see most of the
members there many of the members there
and we've never seen a successful sexual
harassment or sexual assault allegation
against Trump you remember a week or two
ago that wacko eeeek Errol J gene rejean
Carol came out the New York advice
columnist and she said Trump had raped
her then she said no he didn't rape her
then she went on Anderson Cooper said
rape is sexy and then she said a lot of
strange things that obviously show she's
not well was not a credible allegation
which is why the mainstream media
dropped it as quickly as they picked it
up so so as for now I think Trump looks
basically fine here and then there's
Bill Clinton how does this look for
Clinton what are other prominent
Democrats saying about Clinton's role in
this what effect is this going to have
on the Democratic
partying on 20/20 I will also have to
get to the most important question kena
mermaid be black we've got some other
questions to get to too but first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube before I do that guys listen up
to all of you truth loving
cigar-chomping whiskey-drinking seekers
of laughs and merriment and insight
because this is for you we are going to
be taking backstage the daily wire
backstage show on the road we're taking
it on August 21st to Long Beach
California at the Terrace theater and it
is going to be extremely fun Ben Shapiro
the god-king but now verified god-king
jeremy boring andrew Clavin and little
old me will be on stage to discuss the
winners and losers of pop culture and we
will not be flying on Jeffery Epstein's
playing there we are going to be just
takin the bus like regular people you
should be sure to come there as well
tickets are on sale right now at daily
wire comm slash backstage there are
still a few VIP ticket packages
available which include premium seating
photos and meet and greets with each of
us a gift from Ben Shapiro and so much
more come on over if this is your
opportunity to have my book reasons to
vote for Democrats a comprehensive guide
signed by ben shapiro he loves it when
you ask him to sign my book so just make
sure you bring your copy of it there
it's gonna be a lot of fun go to daily
wired icon slash backstage get your
tickets and get ready for a great night
go to daily wire just in general
subscribe we'll be right back
this is bad for Bill Clinton doesn't
look good
I'm not saying certainly that he did
anything but it doesn't look good there
is much less of a reason for Bill
Clinton to be piling around with Jeffrey
Epstein in the early 2000s he was out of
office he wasn't raising money for
himself Hillary Clinton I guess was a
u.s. senator and she was mounting a bid
for president you don't see her piling
around with Epstein too much I mean she
would probably be the main fundraiser
there the other issue for Clinton is
there have been very legitimate sexual
harassment sexual assault claims against
him we all as a nation saw him perjure
himself we all know that he sexually
harassed his 20 year old intern in the
Oval Office
there have been credible allegations
against him for years and include that
includes one serious rape allegation so
things look the worst for Bill Clinton
in all of this which is why the
mainstream media are trying to portray
it as Trump pal Jeffrey Epstein a lot
more ties between Bill Clinton and
Jeffrey Epstein than between Donald
Trump and Jeffrey Epstein the important
thing though is to let things shake out
I think a lot of left wingers are very
excited about this because they think
it's gonna hurt Trump this is what they
did with the Russia investigation and
what did they do there they got oyster
by their own petard on the rush
investigation they thought if we look
into the 2016 interference in the in the
presidential election this is gonna take
down Trump because he was like Rocky and
Bullwinkle he's like what are the two
Russians in Rocky and Bullwinkle
boris and Natasha boris and Natasha he's
like basically a secret double agent for
Russia and they're gonna take him down
and what happens you look into the
Russia interference and you realize it
looks much much worse for Democrats you
realize the only actual foreign
collusion that took place was between
the Hillary Clinton campaign and the
Democratic National Committee and a firm
ColdFusion GPS and an up oh guy named
Christopher steel and Russian
intelligence assets the collusion took
place on the Democrat side it looks
awful it's why the Democrats now are
trying to shut it down I think the same
thing is going to happen here they
rumors of Trump pal Jeffrey Epstein
they're gonna go after Jeffrey Epstein
finally there's way more of a smoking
gun
with prominent Democrats including Bill
Clinton and don't just take my word for
it
Christine Pelosi but does that name
sound familiar Nancy Pelosi's daughter
tweeted just a few days ago quote this
epstein case is horrific and the young
women deserve justice it is quite likely
that some of our faves are implicated
but we must follow the facts and let the
chips fall where they may
whether on Republicans or Democrats
hashtag we said enough hashtag me too
why she's saying this she's saying this
because she knows that this could likely
hit Democrats much harder than
Republicans but we shouldn't make the
mistake that the left does all the time
we shouldn't just jump the gun and say
ha totally we've got him now we we
shouldn't pull a Kavanagh right we
shouldn't we shouldn't shoot before we
aim we shouldn't let this play out and I
strongly suspect it's gonna play out in
the same way that we've seen these other
stories play out I think the left is has
been so whipped up into a frenzy that
they are reopening cases that we would
have wanted reopen ten years ago and
it's probably not going to shake out
very well for them and then you're
probably gonna need to get another
leftist years tumblr because I think
they're gonna overflow well we got to
let the process play out it is a good
thing that this is being reopened and we
shouldn't let the mainstream media get
away with one minute of trying to turn
this into a Republican scandal we've got
to make sure that we follow the facts as
Christine Pelosi says wherever they land
apparently likely on Democrats now
forget this question of whether or not
former President Bill Clinton was
involved with a pedophile sex ring and
Demma Democrat billionaire donor we need
to discuss the most important political
question of the day can mermaids be
black this is it I know it's the
question on everybody's mind Disney
announced last week that the new Little
Mermaid I guess they're doing a
live-action remake something that no one
has asked for the new live-action remake
is going to have a black Little Mermaid
and less
this Twitter exploded with rage about
the imagined racist conservative
response to the black Little Mermaid not
to the real conservative response which
is nobody cares at all but to the
imagined conservative response which is
that conservatives are so furious so
this this thing was trending hashtag not
my Arielle and I looked I said are there
really a lot of conservatives were upset
about this casting the black girl no it
was all left wingers outraged that an
imaginary hypothetical conservative was
hypothetically outraged even though in
real life didn't really happen Linda
Sarsour was talking about this major
left wingers The Washington Post
published a think piece I am using that
term ironically called the white
nostalgia fueling the Little Mermaid
backlash the uproar over a black aerial
shows the importance of representation
in children's entertainment not much
thinking going on in the think piece
there was no backlash there was no
uproar it was a total fiction of the
left so that's hilarious to laugh at we
should always laugh at them getting them
whipped up into a frenzy but what about
the question itself I'm totally willing
to think about the question critically
should the Little Mermaid Ariel be
re-written as a black character I think
there's some pretty good arguments for
it for one their mermaids some mermaids
are mythical creatures they're not about
real creatures doesn't seem like race is
terribly important to a mermaid I've
never met a mermaid in my life but I
suspect it's just as likely I would meet
a black mermaid as a white mermaid
another reason is that it's based on a
fairy tale so fairy tales they tell us
something about culture but they also
tell us a lot about human nature just
universal human drives and so in so much
as fairy tales tell us about human
nature doesn't really matter what the
race of the mythical creature is another
reason why I think it seems perfectly
fine for Ariel to be black is that the
movies being made in the United States
and the United States is a largely
mostly creedal nation founded largely
mostly in ideas rather than on some
particular group of people
some particular ethnicity those are the
arguments for black Ariel there are some
actual arguments against recasting Ariel
with a different race the first is Ariel
has a race and she's Danish the Little
Mermaid is a Danish character invented
by a Danish author named Hans Christian
Andersen and the story takes place off
the coast of Denmark so it's not that it
takes place off the coast of Haiti or
off the coast of Tibet
I don't think Tibet has a coast doesn't
take place off the coast of Japan takes
place in Denmark and Danish people are
white and they're not black and they're
not Asian and they're not native America
another argument here is that Ariel is
already a character she's a character
with certain characteristics one of
which is she has red hair and she's
white this is a similar argument to the
argument against a black James Bond
every few years you hear people talk
about how interés Elba could be the next
James Bond in many ways he'd be a
terrific James Bond he's an excellent
actor he looks the part he's suave right
the argument against a black James Bond
is not that there's anything wrong with
black people it's that James Bond isn't
black he's a character who's British and
he just isn't black when you think about
this with other Disney movies it becomes
clearer
you wouldn't remake Mulan with an Irish
princess you wouldn't say oh it doesn't
matter
you can recast any any type of you know
looking person and it's okay you
wouldn't remake Pocahontas with an
Italian princess that wouldn't make
sense and so if Arielle is Danish if
Ariel has the characteristics she has we
identify her at least by her red hair
then it doesn't make sense to change
that the left is incoherent on this
point because they want to have both
sides of the argument so the left
opposes racial and cultural
appropriation
heaven forfend you dress up like moana
for Halloween heaven forfend you wear a
sombrero on Cinco de Mayo
that would be cultural appropriation
except they support the appropriation of
white cultures so
cultures that we would generally
describe his white they say they don't
really have any particular
characteristics they can be appropriated
by anybody the left also strokes Stokes
rather racial consciousness for every
single racial group they encourage they
love racial consciousness they think
that it will get them a lot more votes
and a lot more political power but then
they condemn the racial consciousness of
Europeans you had at the that Magga hat
wearing Covington Catholic High School
kid when he was in Washington DC is
standing there he was approached by a
group of black supremacists there a
group called the Hebrew Israelites they
viciously hate white people they hate
every group other than their own and
they have these kind of cockamamie
theories about how they are the real
Jews and the Jews or some awful evil
fake Jews or something whatever the
point is they're black supremacists how
did the mainstream media describe them
civil rights activists they're not civil
rights activists their rhetoric is
exactly the same as the Ku Klux Klan but
for black people exactly the same they
have the same sorts of theories they
want the same sorts of political goals
but whereas the media rightly condemns
the Klan the media loves stoking racial
consciousness and racial resentment
among every other group the other side
of this is multiculturalism
multiculturalism seeks to distinguish
every single culture except for most
European cultures which it ceases
generic and universal so I'll say we
don't know white characters don't have
any particular characteristics you know
why that have white characters don't
need to have white characters the race
doesn't matter at all anybody you could
throw anybody in there
but for characters that have non-white
or stories that have non-white
characters you could throw any race in
there this issue is really pronounced
because of America so the United States
is predominantly a creedal country we
were founded by settlers from the
Netherlands and from England and to
lesser degrees from France and Spain we
always were interacting with natives and
we were importing black slaves and a
mayor
erricka from the very beginning has been
multi-racial this is not true of other
countries
what has bound America together since
not just 1776 but since 1620 our ideas
the ideas that sent the pilgrims to
Plymouth and the ideas that launched the
American Revolution the same is not true
in Europe Britain France Italy Denmark
are not creedal countries they're not
countries founded on an idea their
countries founded on people and there
have been migratory movements over the
years and that is the story of those
countries they were founded on people
you cannot just move to England and
become English I'm descended from
Englishmen I can't even move to England
and become English I'm not I'm American
and I look a little too Italian you
can't do it we don't recognize how
special it is that people can just sort
of become Americans it's unbelievable
that you can come here and within I
don't know five or ten years just be
American even less frankly and
ironically it's the same leftists who
indict America as the worst most racist
place on earth they are the ones who are
most oblivious to America's unique
racial tolerance so does anyone actually
care that Disney is making Arial black
no not really what I care about is that
Hollywood has no creativity what I care
about is that the left is totally
contradictory and has to complete double
standards and their total hypocrites I
care that we are just endlessly
rehashing and rewriting old stuff and
the only way we're not making it better
we're making it worse because whenever
we rehash these things we're just adding
a new political twist like we're going
to do Ghostbusters but with women we're
gonna take a really really good movie
and then just insert some aspect of our
ideology into it for no reason and with
no explanation and then it won't that be
good no it's not ended it just obviously
isn't it would be very difficult to
remake Ghostbusters anyway it'd be
basically impossible to remake it and
have it be as good as the original
but if you're only if your only argument
for it is yeah but this time they're
women yeah all right that's like
whatever okay who cares let's do the
Little Mermaid but this time she's black
The Little Mermaid was was good last
time I guess as far as Disney cartoon
movies go you you're not going to it
it's not an excuse do you say oh yeah
it's a man it's a she's black it's
whatever that's that doesn't mean that
you're going to have a better work of
art what it does is it relies on the
political inclinations of people and it
relies on ideology to try to make up for
what is almost certainly not going to be
a great movie I mean none of these
Disney remakes have been any good the
live-action things have been awful I
said through Beauty and the Beast
it was pretty miserable it's uncreate
'iv it's unnecessarily politicized and
it's evidence of an unserious and
decadent society that can't really tell
each other stories anymore and speaking
of stupid racial politics this is this
is what you thought that debating
whether a mermaid can be black the
stupid NBC is now suggesting that Mitch
McConnell cannot oppose reparations or
he has no credibility to or that we
ought to have reparations because Mitch
McConnell's ancestors held slaves this
is the breaking headline senator Mitch
McConnell's great great grandfather's
owned fourteen slaves bringing
reparations issue close to home is it is
that what it's doing they go on Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell who said
recently he opposes paying government
reparations to the descendants of
American slaves has a family history
deeply entwined in the issue two of his
great-great grandfather's were slave
owners u.s. census records show the
details about McConnell's ancestors
discovered by NBC News through a search
of ancestry and census records came in
the wake of recent hearings on
reparations before the House Judiciary
Subcommittee on the Constitution civil
rights and civil liberties asked about
the reparations issue McConnell said he
opposed the idea arguing it would be
hard to figure out whom to compensate
which is obviously the case we've been
talking about that for weeks now let's
say that you are descended from both
slave owners and slave
as many people are is that just a wash
do you get reparations do you get
reparations because you identify more
with the slave part and the slave owning
part do you not get reparations because
vice versa what if you're the descendant
of a black slave owner one of the
earliest slave owners in America
actually the first officially recognized
slave owner in what became our American
system of slavery was a black guy if
you're his descendants do you do you get
reparations what if what if he's only
one of your ancestors then do you only
get that it's impossible to figure out
whom to compensate but they're focusing
on Mitch McConnell maybe they should
focus on 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate Kamala Harris who herself is
descended from a slave owner and this is
not some weird conspiracy theory her
father wrote about this in the Jamaica
globe and explained how quote my roots
go back within my lifetime to my
paternal grandmother miss Chrissy
born Christiana Brown descendent of
Hamilton Brown who is on record as a
plantation and slave owner and founder
of Browns town Kamala Harris is
according to her father the descendant
of a slave owner is her opinion on
reparations no longer valid Kamala
Harris supports reparations
she's descended from a slave owner Mitch
McConnell opposes reparations he's
descended from a slave owner whose
opinion is right based on the
credibility of their ancestors you know
the Knowles's george cobb knowles fought
for the Union to free the slaves in the
Civil War he died at the Battle of
Boynton plank road I opposed reparations
I'm the only one of those three people
who doesn't descend from a slave owner
and actually my forebears died fighting
for the freedom of the slaves
so I guess my opinion counts right I
have the best opinion on it okay good so
we're not gonna have any reparations of
course this is a ridiculous way to
resolve political questions it shows the
absurdity of the reparations issue I
don't care who Kamala Harris's
great-great-grandfather was I don't care
who Mitch McConnell's great-great
great-grandfather was I sort of care who
my great-great great-grandfather was but
only as a historical curiosity not
because I think it means that my opinion
is more worthwhile that way this is what
the left gets for giving us tribal Paula
for a politics that doesn't have
anything to do with a reason it's the
politics of grievance of oppression of
intersectionality if I can prove that my
ancestors were more historically
slighted then everyone has to do what I
say
that is an illogical anti reasonable
point of view the way that
self-government works is when we
convince each other of things it's when
we persuade our fellow citizens if it's
just gonna be a contest of grievance and
whose great-great
great-great-grandfather washed more
floors than whoever else is
great-great-great great-grandfather we
don't have much of a republic anyway so
much more to get to go we're out of time
I guess we'll get to it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show alleged crap stain
Jeffrey Epstein has been arrested again
for allegedly raping and pimping
allegedly underage girls like the
alleged scumbag he allegedly is as a
result Epstein's Wikipedia entry is
being rewritten to edit out
Epstein's good pal Bill Clinton and
labor secretary Alex Acosta is being set
up as the sole scapegoat because a cost
that provides a tenuous connection
between Epstein and Donald Trump the
coverage of this story is going to
reveal who among journalists and
politicians cares about the truth and
who only cares about preserving Democrat
power will talk about it on the Andrew
Klavan show Andrew Clavin